what you
oui
génial et qui trop bien et c'est moi
c'est drôle à tous pas s'arrêter là
c'était formidable c'est vraiment très
très bon sachez dave il n'a qu'une fois
là j'ai adoré j'ai trouvé ça magnifique
pour s'écouler pour toutes les aides ça
va plaire à toutes les générations
l'amitié c'est l'amour je le sens de la
vie tchô
c'est par ici
j'ai beaucoup aimé le run off je
trouvais très rigolo qu'on s'ennuie pas
c'est une très très belle aventure si tu
sais piloter un avion toi accroche toi
ici je suis pas sûr que la grande
aventure ya la petite fille comme le
petit prince en long voyage initiatique
pour tous les virus une aventure le même
s'il faut mourir une transition
c'est le film de l'été il faut
absolument les voies suivantes
eh bien cette fois l'art